um so we have a computer and a monitor
in here
and it's a strength training machine and
you have to install it is there like a
monthly subscription like uh they do
with that peloton that all the kids are
crazy
it's 40 49 a month uh gives you video
video based guidance expert led programs
that go multiple weeks to help you
achieve your goals
and uh and it's it's more than just a tv
mounted a strength training machine it's
the world's most advanced piece of
fitness equipment
this is a digital weight system a
digital weight system
so i notice there's no uh there's no
weight stack there's no weight stack
with that
whatever that piece of metal you put in
there and hope doesn't break and crush
your toes yeah that's right
that's a pin none of that there's no pin
uh it's digital
uh you simply select the weight with
this dial
you can select it in one pound
increments and uh and it instantly
gives you weight got it so if i pull on
this that's 28 pounds of weight
got it coming off of this and there's no
weight stack it's electromagnetic
electromagnetic yes so inside of there
when you say
28 pounds it tells the magnets
to give that amount of resistance that's
right there's there's a there's an
algorithm running inside it
that resists you and because it's an
algorithm it can be dynamic
and do all sorts of interesting things
so have you ever been uh
been at the gym working out alone and
wish you had a buddy to spot you
not really candidly but i'm a loaner but
yes theoretically i would but i'm a
narcissist i'd rather be alone yeah fair
enough well
you know for me i was going to the gym
at 6 00 in the morning it was hard to
get someone to go with me yeah
and so this is this is a system with 29
pounds and
and that's 29 pounds of force on this
row but if it sees me begin to struggle
it will automatically get and shave a
little weight off that's 26 pounds
i struggle some more you know 23 pounds
it will
shave the weight off until i'm able to
to keep going and this is it's a great
way
to be able to to take to push yourself a
little bit harder and get more gains
and this is really one of the many many
benefits of digital weights
uh weight is it's never been digitized
before
uh you go to the gym today and cardio
machines have screens on them and weight
machines are just hunks of metal
this is the first time it's been
digitized cheaper
smaller and better more intelligent
yeah wow and it's got an algorithm who
could ask for anything more
so you have one of the traders here i
see you have these celebrity trainers
these coaches
and i know liz is super popular here in
san francisco so can she come in and
show us how to do this
yeah absolutely all right let's bring in
liz hey liz how are you good
so you're an instructor list i am yes
uh what are you what have you done
previously um
so i currently work one-on-one with
clients now i've worked in group fitness
settings i've worked right now i'm
working on my phd
so not only am i bringing the fitness
component
working one-on-one one-on-one with
people but i have this whole sports
medicine background that i like to bring
to my programming
both individually and here on tunnel
this is
a great platform okay so you're gonna
show us how to select a workout is are
these live classes that you do here like
that peloton system where people bike
and
that costs like five grand that's super
expensive um or is this more like uh
watch videos how does it work well these
are these are based on multi-week
programs
so rather than giving you a live
experience which is a lot more like
group fitness
this is more like having a personal
trainer with you in real life
that creates programs that go multiple
weeks so our programs will go four or
six weeks
and they're always oriented around a
specific goal
if you go to the gym and do random
things you'll get random results but if
you have an
expert create a program for you with
specific
exercises each day you'll achieve real
results that way so you onboard the
person i guess
and then pick a program for them yeah so
people select
their goals whether it's you want to
lose weight you want to
train for a marathon or you're an elite
athlete and you need to continue with
your training
and then so we help guide them and
select in their selection
of a program that's appropriate for them
i just want to stop embarrassing jason
statham and daniel craig at the beach so
i just want to put a couple extra pounds
on because those guys are getting a
little bit jealous but
that joke did land i guess